avez-vous tué Meredith Kercher non étiez-
vous là cette nuit-là non savez-vous
quelque chose que vous n'avez pas dit à la police non les
Italiens appellent cela le procès de
la décennie nous n'étions pas les meilleurs amis mais j'ai
été tellement choqué par ce qui lui est arrivé que
les amis sont  en nous disant comment Fernanda
s'était comportée en faisant des roues de charrette
et en s'embrassant cela n'a pas l'
air génial je veux dire qui se comporte comme
ça qui elle l'a fait elle est folle
Becky La Colonia meepo aujourd'hui Darla
répond Missy McKee une responsabilité
qui est le cauchemar de tout le monde non plus je suis un
psychopathe déguisé en mouton ou je suis
toi du coup je me suis retrouvé jeté dans
cet endroit sombre j'avais tellement peur
je ne sais pas quoi dire d'autre
avant l'Italie j'ai eu une vie heureuse c'était
très important pour moi de sortir de ma
zone de confort  et voir si cela m'a fait
devenir un adulte quand j'étais mais
Amanda c'était tellement heureux ce qui s'est passé cette nuit-là
Amanda Knox je veux dire que certaines des
informations qui sont sorties étaient juste
complètement inventées, elles ont fait la une des journaux
au cours du procès mondial de la décennie c'est
juste fou
le monde entier savait avec qui j'avais déjà eu des
relations sexuelles elle était terrifiée
je me sentais à nouveau comme un enfant et je savais
que j'étais un enfant